it's they're a cooperative one yes
actually bomb defusal is cooperative
perfect yeah this one is real tough well
that's okay because the other ones are
so easy all right all right okay so
since this is what's cooperative listen
listen with your ears so you start with
drills see the screws in the four
corners you have to grab the drills do
not stab yourself with my drill
apologize to yourself because it'll kill
you he's got touch it to the top of the
screw I'm trying but my hand is like not
moving anymore
well and then it's just moved on its own
well that's unfortunate
why is it moving on its own because it
it's how I don't know man physics in
this game don't make any sense
wait did you drop your drill no there
you can have mine thank you okay I guess
that is one way to do it yeah that makes
sense
oh now it works oh oh now flip my hand
kinda right click and rode to a dish oh
really trying
I will accept donations do you want this
here take it take it take it take it
god this game there you go there we go
there we go oh my god cooperate please
press the button so how much time do
guarding this bomb not a lot well no
once we get it open
know we'll know if we just oh my god you
two are pokey all you made in Rus ia
that's pretty good where's Russia
I don't know but it sounds exotic I
ain't
interesting I think roughs I ate was in
that song you know Bermuda drew maker
Ross I you know yeah the Guv I'm Ross I
a comes walking in yeah no not that way
very exotic place yeah
sunshine ninety days out of the year
yeah ninety well I think that's one way
of diffusing it oh my god your body's a
for effort okay don't worry okay we'll
get it this time I'm gonna grab the
steak yes listen I just wanted to give
an inspirational speech do it
we are bomb defusal experts we've been
training for this for years we know
exactly don't touch my hands don't know
that's not part of it alright continue
all right we have been training for
years for this we want to go home to our
families after this we are gonna defuse
this and it'll be like nothing when
we're gonna prove a point by not wearing
any bomb defusal equipment we don't need
armor
we don't need cheese hats to keep our
big thinkers fresh exactly and break
just don't drop the drill is all I ask
just drop the drill okay maybe they're
drills in Russia
maybe Russ is the drill capital it's
okay I got one one screw coming out
coming at you like Cleopatra there you
go wow that's good stuff that's some
good stuff okay you remember your
training
do you remember the speech the speech I
gave about our families
Ross I a Ross I a what you remember Ross
I a No here can you hand me that bad boy
perfect
that's leave it there it'll be fine okay
stop right here I don't want to like
mess with your jam right now give it a
once-over I gotta make sure I know what
the model is you know I I work by touch
it's fine Ross I a craftsman ship well
yeah real attractive two floors gravity
is very happy with these bad boys
yeah they got quantum cores in them yep
really weird you know I can honestly
pass you mine if you want you know why
not yeah I got that rousing speech and
belittling of us that you did in the
first time a little thank you thank you
thank you thank you so I have a steady
hand on yours I believe in you I
appreciate it I appreciate it we'll get
this we'll get through this please don't
help me out actually it would be more
good thank you and now I'll pass it back
to you so you can get the job done right
there for no no no no no that's not it
Wow it's okay here you go
just take a firm grasp of that use your
grippers there pokey use those grippers
yeah they call them phalanges yeah
because they fall and yeah you know like
this angle for gripping is perhaps not
ideal oh okay I actually I'm gonna toss
it into your other hand okay ready three
two one catch there you go there you go
Sonic solid perform now is great catch
now if you were showing it off like a
teacup this would be great don't be
afraid of the drill yeah don't be afraid
your face it's more afraid of you than
you are of it I put my hand in the bomb
so it doesn't go anywhere okay oh that's
you just wanted to show it off me yes
well
Ross Iook after and ship right there
dance quantum core on that bad boy
you see perfect so you wanna put the
drill right where the screw is it's over
on the right side now yes yes so the
diagram is so that sound you heard was
not our tinnitus kicking in I need you
this one more time and I need a fin I
get this stupid screw okay okay alright
you guys friends real bad yeah okay
scroll your hands up into the air first
if you couldn't your pokie your left
hand is just right in the way of my
that's okay
it's don't move don't move okay it's
fine yes oh sorry my hand was in the way
lefty there well put her on the table
gets even easier when you realize you
don't actually have to put it straight
on yeah yeah yeah angles are fine I feel
like that was a lesson I learned in a
life once past long long ago look it's
been a while
alright we're good I think we got this
one in the bag as they say there we go
there we go magnetism all right you got
this try righty Andy no no no you gotta
oh he's perfect perfect Rob right ease
that's oh oh oh there she goes alright
two more shots
you won't drink that take my drill not
my drool not sure that's safe his drill
doesn't even work properly it's not even
running my drill can't even turn it off
it's nuts don't cry don't cry don't cry
don't cry bomb defuse those don't cry
it's okay Casey France this screw right
here yeah yeah that screw that's the one
all right take it yeah dick firmly grasp
it ah the backwards grip I like it I
like it I like there you go it's when
you get them in a certain part of your
back you that that arm is dead forever
it will never come back yes part of your
back what do you mean if you get your
arm behind you in a certain part of your
back it's dead oh yeah
you add the demons in you I don't think
you're smiling
one last college try I recommend putting
your your other hand on the table like
just flat on the table oh my god put
your left arm flat on the table all
right it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine fine we're in this together
everybody at what point can I just run
out the
in scream at what point is wisdom gonna
take over well you know what guys it's
not quarantine it's corn team pokey all
right they're the demons
yep the demons yep that's the demons
okay demons you got it let's just see if
we open up the bomb we win yeah yeah
yeah they're here take mine take mine
this game says oh don't hit bang Donaire
bang just a perfectly positioned so you
can grab that push up on the drill part
so it 'angels a bit better before you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so whew you got it silence there
you go that's a good angle that's a good
angle
you know what cotton I think she might
go to Nationals with this whoa there you
go you're kind of pressing it and that's
all I matter just point it down put it
on that screw okay never nor let it go
oh you're so close that's perfect that's
a good angle
that's good angle let's let's fix this
angle we go just go that's a good angle
stop pushing stop forcing yes one click
or two clicks one click just watch it
click it just click and hold okay I like
this
turkey claw you guys came out pretty
good it's good stuff if you were if you
were person to bond right now this would
be why I like move my arm properly in
front of it it's one of you guys presses
the button um sure listen if I could do
it for you I was this bad boy right here
it's going places Oh
going places it's going in that place
it's gonna go in that place and this
part of you probably those goddamned FPS
games you're playing it's a bunch of
crap which games this is a YouTube game
no no you got this you got no you are
letting us down super are you guys we
would love to would love to oh yeah curl
that there's much more to this than just
[Music]
you know yeah it is yeah you know what's
fun after you open the box there's five
more puzzles yeah and opening the box
wasn't even a puzzle that's just like
opening the bag of cereal yeah over the
bag of milk whichever one you want to
say whichever sorry it's okay I'm only
crushingly disappointed maybe I'll
practice up this game yeah well dude I
know you won don't even say you won't do
it you won't I don't think it was a
valiant effort I will say it really
wasn't for me in my own way oh good
though that's good then that's good what
as long as you can sleep at night like
an RPG that's quick
we could try RPG yeah that that'd be
cool yeah I've never done it isn't it
like the grenade one where we just have
RPGs and we just have to put one in and
shoot each other
dig it in there and then blast it I feel
like after the last one cooperative
clearly it's nurse phones you know we're
we're so far away from each other Oh
yeah okay you don't need to yell sorry
it's all I know
no no wait what do we even do here Oh Oh
No Oh
the art of RP cheating oh no oh this is
easy it's already lined up okay that's
the opposite ones real pain in the ass
can't believe they did it like this no
oh no it's not lined up it's so weird
and I can't believe that well sounds oh
well test fireworks that's good does it
click in oh yeah it does
dying look we're really good at this
game oh wait I know I know it's very
impressive how about you Oh goddamn it
markiplier okay okay okay okay okay okay
dude what are those random sounds it's
war is what is war war kills us all or
okay front row show to that and some
other stuff that I didn't quite want to
see but okay a little lower you need a
little lower I'm just happy that this is
doing it whoa - hi
god damn it can it just be over oh then
reset reset I don't a fight against
degree MA degree MA
why do you say about degree buff well I
mean sir what does it even mean quite
clear the degree must just nasal I don't
think the agreement was doing any better
so oh no what what there's so far how
are you supposed to get him there so far
away
because I knocked him that's why yeah I
did too okay here we go here we go here
we go that's right in the chamber right
in the chamber there you go yeah it's
something about the hole the way it is
yeah it's only the the entire purpose
yes it's awful
you know everyone who plays this game
says the same things oh my god they're
too far away they're too far away I just
need to turn it at one of you and then
it's over for you [ __ ] don't call us
[ __ ] that's derogatory sorry
but I need to kill you if I swear if I
push this thing away one more freaking
time okay I need to kill you that's fine
that is fine that's fine that's the
nature of the business God how do i turn
my god
the son of a [ __ ] this piece of garbage
I can't even aim it at either of you I
don't know how the hell I can turn it at
your direction I just have it in the air
that's great that's great yeah that's
great great RPG great stuff this is
great
okay I'm clicking I'm locked on baby I
just can't aim it at you
yeah well common bro aim it straight
okay Lords what they call a damn shame
you know they call it crying damn shame
everything is so out of reach it's like
I'm a five-year-old I don't know like I
just accidentally moved everything out
of range
I almost did that do didn't even shoot
that's okay okay okay okay I gotta put
this bad boy on my shoulder put it on my
shoulder good luck with that load it on
you know what actually I don't even need
that the
I saw that let's see I'll help you no
[Music]
it's not letting me push it I'm sorry
man it's all over all right can you
reset it oh no man I don't know Judy
Bing Bing all right this is gonna be the
one okay so and steady wins the race
I disagree okay my RPG is in it sounded
like someone blew up yeah it started the
run always has an explosion okay okay
how do I turn it forward dude I gotta
get the pro tips from pokey you're never
gonna get good at this game unless you
read her no no no she knows how to do it
yeah your mouse 32 degrees in Northwest
that's what it is you should be good I
don't know where North is well there's
your first problem you gotta get a
compass are you gonna play that compass
for getting air scrubber
I gotta tell you you might maybe you
should be a little bit worried he's a
little locked and loaded but he's locked
and loaded - I'm just trying to aim it
slow and steady wins the race
am I still in trouble there you are
buddy that scared the crap out of me
I literally was a fungus I
why do they fly away all right once more
once more this will be the one this mode
is poopy no your poopy how do you guys
grab the grenades without I'm exploding
very carefully degree m'as gone Oh No I
knocked all my Rockets away that sucks
for you man no I got one I got one
okay I'm locked in you know how the hell
does the rest of this thing work what
happens every shooted while holding the
rocket I don't know if that'll oh oh
okay
well it's it's excessively harder for me
to aim left than it is right isn't it
pokey isn't it a little bit difficult
for me thank you yeah
think about him when you're dying I'm
telling you we're gonna play this again
sometime and I'm gonna lower my DPI and
it's gonna be insanely better oh yeah I
understand I'm a professional game it's
just the deep I'm sure it's witnessing
the amazing work I'm doing right here
right now
the real bald head and it's not me it's
not me yes don't even think about it
because I am so oh my god he won't lift
it my body's getting in the way looking
I can't not quite not quite not quite
you're done for now
mark ah life's good life's good because
I am about to destroy another human
being it is I who can't reach his hoar
PG now Wow imma be honest I wasn't even
close
yeah when I heard it I was like oh wait
there's no way he's gonna hit you even
know why it went like perfectly alive
and then fully straight up it was it was
really lined up well Jishan if you need
to know I literally can't reach my thing
anymore why is that even a thing
why are you able to knock it away where
you can't reach it anymore cuz they're
looking wait I still have RPGs no yeah
no he must out your snake impression I
love it every pogies got the best snake
impression come on
yeah he's got the best solid snake all
day yeah is that your first video yeah
I'm doing a snake impression really yeah
yeah no it's horrifying
I mean it's epic it's whatever I'm
somewhat of a voice actor it's I need to
keep talking about it forever
right yeah yeah good game today and I
will make sure to be a slightly bit
better at hand simulator next time we
play I promise we can have a bet next
round if I'm not significantly better
because I know what I need to do okay
okay what's what's the bet what's the
bet
oh it's the wager is a wager you know
what sit on it thank you something good
will come back for the next video with a
good idea okay sort of a gambler I see
very ominous very ominous okay you're on
[Music]